Ruby began identifying as male at 13
years old now 21
she'd been planning to have surgery to
remove her breasts but in May she made
the decision to come off testosterone
and D transition to identify as female
her sex at birth she doesn't want to be
identified so we've changed her name I
figured it would be better for me to try
to deal with my gender dysphoria in a
different way rather than permanently
changing my body how much support did
you feel was out there for you when you
came to this conclusion I didn't feel
like there was any support out there
other than like a few friends online
Ruby now feels her eating disorder was
more of a factor than she first realized
in her gender dysphoria none of the
therapists I spoke to brought that up
they didn't think that it was linked do
you I think so yes because it they're
both kind of based in how I feel about
my body
so I've seen similarities between the
two Charlie Evans is forming a charity
to support people in Ruby's position
after going public with her D transition
story she discovered an online community
of 5,000 in a similar position 30 people
alone in her area of New Castle I was
approached by a young woman um with a
beard and she hugged me and and said I'm
a D transitioned women as well we've
just stopped taking testosterone and
after that I felt like I had to do
something I'm hearing from hundreds of
people um and I think some of the common
characteristics are they tend to be
around their mid-twenties and they're
mostly female and mostly same-sex
attracted most lesbians and often
autistic as well the Tavistock and
Portman NHS trusts told us the
experience of regret described here is
extremely rare their gender identity
service for children in Leeds in London
now has a record number of referrals the
clinics here and in London see 3000
percent more patients than they did 10
years ago
among girls referrals are up more than
5,000%
there's no question this service is
helping children who feel distressed in
their own bodies with a full impact of
children making decisions about their
gender at such young ages may not truly
be clear until much later in their lives
but 21 it's had a positive outcome for
Jamie and his mum after testosterone and
surgical treatment
he's far happier than the torment of his
teenage years it was kind of hell I it's
just not something you wanted to go
through if you were trying this like
like me it's just it's awful like
everything that happens to you within
that stage of you before a female it's
for a trans man it's awful there's
currently no data for how many in the
trans community D transition and to talk
about it can be viewed as transphobic
but people like Ruby say more discussion
is needed as well as more options for
people with gender dysphoria sally
Lockwood Sky News